so i promised that i would do some more
10 shorts answering subscribers
questions
posed to me in in youtube
uh so here are 10 more they're kind of
all over the map uh no common theme to
them other than they deal with
philosophy more or less
in one way or another
here's a question that comes to me from
uh schwarzschaft
and he asked do you think that the coen
brothers cult movie the big lebowski is
the american equivalent to camus
novel the stranger
and at first i was thinking no that that
doesn't really make sense but now that i
think about it given some of the
elements of what's going on
it could make sense the only thing is
what do you do with those german
nihilists you know actually that'd be a
little bit more like camus
letters to a german friend wouldn't it
um
so the big lebowski you've got this guy
the dude and
he's played by jeff bridges and he's
living this life
along with his two bowling buddies
where he's just sort of floating
drifting along and that is kind of like
uh marseille in the stranger
there are some catalyzing moments
there's nothing like the the actual you
know killing of the arab on the beach
for him
uh his friend does die and they scatter
his ashes
he gets caught up in
i don't know the big lebowski in some
respects is is more of a
whodunit kind of kind of movie as well
uh because there's that mystery involved
in it
and there's no you know bringing
everything to a climax the way there is
in the second part of
the stranger as a matter of fact the
entire second part of the stranger
is concerned with the thematic of
freedom and its loss what was taken for
granted in the earlier
part so
you know if you if you grant those
things you could say that the big
lebowski is absurdist you could say
that there is a character who's just
kind of floating but i think you could
say that about a lot of
other american movies
so it's not as if it's like the best fit
so
zimniac uh kosmosu and i apologize if i
got your name wrong in this asks me
are there now any living philosophers
worth studying and i'd say yeah there's
there's a whole lot of them who are
alive and whose works are well worth
engaging with i certainly find them
interesting
philosophy now did a
survey which
i don't actually place much stockings i
don't find many of the people that they
they uh they put in there to be very
interesting myself but you know you can
take a look at it they they uh
surveyed their their readers and you
know who are the top people alive today
who are worth studying the one guy in
there who i
do like that um i i would say as well
we're spending some time on is jurgen
habermas not only in terms of his own uh
projects but his readings on on other
people
um i if i had to pick one person who i
think is well worth studying today who's
currently alive it would be aleister
mcintyre
his work spans decades
you know very deep
and covers a lot of stuff
very interesting figure
some other people who i've run into
or or benefited from
um
you know paul griffiths comes to mind
um there's there's you know various
people i've been impressed with um
here and there but
you know to answer the question very
simply yes they're they're we're not in
a time where there aren't a lot of
people doing great philosophical work
but you got to do a little bit of work
to
to track them down and and find them
um even you know people
like uh slavojijak i find interesting um
i like quite a quite a bit of his
earlier stuff
um and you know so is he worth studying
definitely worth studying i'm not sure
you would take on his his perspective
necessarily
so this is a long overdue answer to one
of the questions that mark smith put a
long time ago
as a medium that allows probably the
greatest amount of interaction with the
work itself do you think video games
allow us to address or experience
certain way certain issues in ways not
possible with other formats so the
simple answer is yes
i think that there's a lot that you can
do with the format of video games
whether you're talking about you know
forex strategy
games or you're talking about
uh first person shooter games or sandbox
games or you know pick pick there's a
whole variety of different types of
simulations
yeah you know we can do things over and
over in games we can try things out we
can engage with with other
players in ways that are very
interesting i think
and
um
could these be adapted for
conveying some some interesting
philosophical
ideas
or trying out philosophical perspectives
i think the answer is yes
i think there's a lot more work that
needs to be done on that you may
remember i actually did
a conversation with a young games
designer where we're trying to reach
sort of mutual ground
him coming at you know asking about
ethics and and philosophy and critical
thinking from over here where he knows a
lot about games and their design and how
they work and me over here not knowing
quite so much about games but knowing a
lot about the subject area and trying to
find that common ground where we could
say yeah games could definitely be used
for something very interesting
um
so yeah i i would say
that's that's definitely the case i
think that's not only the case for
philosophy
but for other kinds of experiences as
well
i'm not a fan of guitar hero but i like
the fact that guitar hero has introduced
a lot of young people to great heavy
metal classics
that they otherwise wouldn't have heard
so you know we could come up with a lot
of examples i think
so here's a question having to do with
the history of philosophy and theology
to what extent where plato and
neo-platonism regarded as compatible
with christian theology so to answer
that question you gotta you gotta
specify a little bit
there's no such thing as christian
theology per se
there are schools of christian theology
there are movements tendencies
and there are important figures
uh and the you know the answer that you
can give is that for very many of them
particularly in the patristic era
running all the way through the middle
ages and even you know in certain
resurgences afterwards think about the
cambridge plateness for example
plato and
neoplatonism were considered to be
if not
you know getting there to to the
logos as as christ at least having some
conception
of the logos and of you know
participation and something like theosis
becoming divine
a lot of christian thought was was taken
almost wholesale
you know rejecting certain elements of
course
uh
into patristic theology and i myself
actually consider that a good thing
because i think plato
um
metaphysically and and ethically got got
a number of things right
augustine himself is a great example of
this he's he's uh you know working in
that that neo-platonist mold
um he calls them the platonus but he
means neoplatonus and
you know clement of alexandria another
great case lactancias justin martyr
these guys were all very impressed by by
platonic philosophy
so christopher dunn asks the question
what is aquinas's purpose in writing the
work the summa contra gentiles
and traditionally it's been understood
as being
a book that was written to help
missionaries or apologists to
combat um what were perceived as being
the errors
of the the infidels the unfaithful those
who did not accept the
christian and specifically
catholic understanding of the christian
faith
and to do so by appealing to
natural reason and the arguments that we
can we can create from from those bases
so
you know who would have been the
gentiles in this case pagans and and um
muslims who would not have accepted say
the old testament with with you know
jews you could still appeal to the old
testament or for the jews the testament
the tenet
um
whereas you know for
for for christians you could appeal to
the new testament and say look you're
misinterpreting this or that but for
other people maybe then then arguments
from natural reason are the best bet so
that's the traditional understanding of
that there have been some scholars who
have called that into question but
um you know it does seem pretty
pretty clear that the book is apologetic
in purpose it is supposed to provide
some sort of reasoned
defense for art for you know
the the main things comprising christian
faith
so zimniac uh kosmosu has another very
interesting question here this one's
specifically about american philosophy
what precisely were the intellectual
sources of transcendentalist philosophy
so let's let's keep in mind who we're
talking about here we're talking about
this movement that's in the early 1800s
primarily in new england you know
spreading into some other areas um
transcendentalist is one of those
slippery kind of titles and movements
you know who was in who was out
um you know definitely emerson was in
uh channing's was in you know some other
people but you know
what about other
figures like is thoreau a
transcendentalist yeah i guess so you
know what about you know whitman
you know there there's different
interpretations of just how we ought to
define the term
um the term transcendentalist though is
is uh showing you
one important aspect of their thought so
that's what i'm going to concentrate on
here
and
they're they're
focusing on the transcendental
philosophy that's coming from germany
what we nowadays call german idealism
uh but they're getting it largely
through the intermediary of of the
english particularly coleridge
one of the key ideas about the
transcendental philosophy that got
interpreted in very different ways by
different people was that there's the
understanding or in german firsthand and
then there's reason
uh you know fernand and that as a
faculty that
grasps things that the understanding
can't the understanding is great for the
the empirical world
and concepts and stuff like that but but
reason
grasps the deeper
truth
that you know
may be difficult to communicate so it
was tied in with some mysticism some of
the transcendentalists were also
interested in
what they understood of indian
philosophy at the time they're reacting
against the
lockheed
and
common sense empiricism
that's coming to them either you know
from from england or through you know
people like jonathan edwards so that's
that's the story there
so christopher dunn asks what are my
thoughts on michelle foucault and his
ideas of biopower and biopolitics or i
suppose if i'm going to you know like be
very accordion about this biopoer and
biopolitique you know um
but
well you know i think there's something
to it i i don't think that foucault is
um saying something as revolutionary as
many people
take him to be saying it's interesting
the basic notion is that
um
in modernity
one of the major changes that comes
about in part through the the rise of
the nation state and you know we can
also extend this into the agency of the
marketplace and stuff like that is the
focus on
the human life
the body
and all the things that that connect
with it acquiring information about it
manipulating it
and understanding it not only in an
individuating way but in a mass you know
so we can think about things like public
health for example
as a prime example of what what foucault
calls biopower or you know since it's
very
very timely think about you know
infectious diseases in particular
ebola and the worries about contagion
and the discussions about you know the
possible politics of confinement and
quarantine that would all be part of
what foucault was calling um
biopolitics you know
if you look for example at the worries
about these people that were taken to
emery
and um
or this doctor you know how do we know
that he's not actually going to bring
ebola into to uh make us all sick well
that's that's part of the information
gathering that that comprises um
biopower
so is there something to this yeah
there's something to it is it is it as
important as as some people talk about
it you know in very you know reverential
tones probably
so uh ziemniak cosmos who asks an
interesting question particularly for me
having gone to southern illinois
university having worked at the dewey
center
do the works of john dewey have an
impact on american life and the answer
is is yes and no
in any sort of direct way no because the
works of john dewey are barely read
and many of the people who read them uh
admit that they are they are quite
obscure
and often uh i won't say poorly written
but but very ambiguous and hard to
puzzle out he was not the the most uh
clear writer he's you know he he was
influenced by hegel
in some respects uh and he did pick up
hegel's tendency towards you know
cyclopean architecture of sentences
let's call it um
he did influence american education
quite a bit
and
you find a lot of american educators and
philosophers of education who view him
as this you know great
revered
grandfather
figure of progressive education um that
that places him you know
not only on the pedestal for some people
but into the pit for many other people
they credit dewey for all sorts of you
know aberrations in our culture that
really probably
ought not to be just attributed to dewey
alone but um because it takes a you know
it takes a lot of people to do that sort
of thing
um so did the works of john dewey have
an impact on american life yes
what kind of impact did they have it's
not quite so cut and dry to say exactly
what it was he certainly
spurred um
you know a tendency towards progressive
education
a lot of the people that are doing you
know what they call progressive
education now don't think that that you
know he went far enough or they think
that his insights have not been
incorporated
um you know there's a lot to be said
about that
mark smith asks another question about
video games as well
do you think video games can
or should be classified as art
this is a very interesting question
and it's provoked a lot of discussion
and a lot of feelings one way or another
because you know
let's say we put aside the we none of us
know what art is anymore sort of
post-modernist stuff you know we say
well we are familiar with some genres of
art and even let's let's be really in
their view very conservative and say
figurative art is is where it's at you
know um splotches on on canvases that
can mean something and and you know
total cacophony
that's interesting but you don't get
much mileage out of it
um
traditionally art has has involved some
sort of you know
figure or some sort of development in
time
something recognizable with themes
now the question we can ask is do video
games have that
and the answer is yes
you know i don't want to say that
centipede had it
or
you know
galaga or you know these arcade games
there could be some
kitschy
element to that
but if we're talking about games that
have a very
complex developed narrative the way that
some of the games that we see today do
there's a lot of artistry involved there
are they art
i think so and you know
if you think about games in terms of
what was called the gazonte queens of uh
virk uh the total artwork
you have games that are incorporating
incredible visuals
a lot of music that is being developed
by by composers specifically for those
games a lot of really interesting music
and an experience
that incorporates the player and
actually has them engaged with their
agency i think there's a case to be made
there that that it's a new kind of art
so this is a more personal question
about emotions that came to me a while
back from obey 623 and it runs like this
i want to ask what makes it so that a
person can't get rid of
of regret or
won't let go of failure
of something or to make someone stop
believing in the idea of romantic love
very uh
problematic situation that that many of
us find ourselves in
where we say
i don't like the way i'm feeling
i don't like what's happened i don't
like what my role in it was i don't like
where this is going but i can't you know
stamp my fingers and stop feeling
this way
so
he's asking what what are the conditions
that make it so that this is the case
and i don't think that you can say that
there is one single general schema that
you can put all of this in
you you do have to look at this in a
way that focuses on the person and the
relationships that they're in and their
understandings
of relationships and of themselves
that's not to say that it's like totally
you know up for grabs none of us can
compare it you know to each other where
all these
per you know
little monads or as we now call it
unique snowflakes
i think there are some general
trends that you can point at but there's
there's no one single thing in some
cases it could be
that
a person
put so much
into that relationship
that
the very act of grieving it that would
get them past it and allow them to to be
open to something new
is too painful
or it could be that they feel a sense of
shame and that motivates them so much
that they can't look at what's happening
and it's better to feel these other
feelings than to feel shame
some people and i'm not saying this is
the case in this case
might even derive some sort of
satisfaction or
something from being stuck in a
situation like that there are many other
possibilities as well